i'm so good my fellow canadian i know we
got a lot just happen to always have
these canadian teams on the show i don't
know how that works out right okay we do
well we have a great connection we've
also done a lot with warframe over the
years and i know right now anyone
watching on twitch for more than 30
minutes this show is going to get a
special twitch drop right that's right i
already have seen people getting it so
it's very exciting she's right there
loud and proud protea 30 minutes for
watching thank you for letting us kind
of take over your special events
category but she is there and she is for
you if you are properly linked up no
warframe you know as i said we've done a
lot over the years you guys have done
incredible things with the game and i
know you have tennocon coming up in july
which is your big kind of event of the
year to reveal what's next what what can
you tell us well i can't tell too much
but yeah july 16 2022 it's a digital
event again this year
today actually we just launched the
digital items for it so you can get some
in-game goodies some really cool
cosmetics some merch all that really
great stuff went live today but of
course the reason i'm here
is to you know kind of debut we have our
tenno live during tennocon which is our
big reveal of the night and we usually
do is a little bit of a gameplay a
little bit of a demo and i think a lot
of people can suspect what it might be
but i'm here to kind of confirm what it
is that tunnel live is going to show
and what is that
can i say it yes i think you can okay
you're going to get your first look at
the diviri paradox finally i know i know
it's been a couple years uh but de vere
paradox is going to be what tennolive is
all about and i'm so happy the team
worked really hard on the teaser you're
about to see for it and i'm just really
proud and excited to show it awesome
well thanks so much for being here on
summer game fest let's take a look at
that right now
[Music]
my child
my friend
what was done is done
dangers
new choices await us now
[Music]
[Music]
for now
dream of who we were
and of who we have become
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you